[Music]
this is the Hawaii most visitors never
see an hour from the luxury hotels and
shops in the farthest corner away from
Honolulu
it's the Hawaiian Hawaii working class
and proudly natives where locals will
tell you Hawaii is occupied by the u.s.
that it has been for 124 years and that
it will one day be free we came here to
see the native sovereignty movement in
action we are driving through Waimanalo
which is a stronghold of the sovereignty
movement here in Hawaii and we're headed
to a village in the hills that was
established by a sovereignty group
called the nation of Hawaii the village
is called refuge of Waimanalo with a
population of roughly 80 the state
handed the group 45 acres of land in the
90s after it occupied a popular beach
for over a year bumpy kanahele is a
group leader and head of the village do
you have your own passport here in the
nation of Hawaii we have things ready to
turn on for the passport can I apply for
when they are banning with ones under us
we take any citizenship application
boozled any of you disrupted Americans
want to come on by come to awaken visit
us in a wall and we'll be more than
happy to accommodate then learn about US
history and for Native Hawaiians it's a
painful history in 1893 armed u.s. naval
forces helped American sugar plantation
owners overthrow Hawaii's Queen the
provisional government that was set up
after ceded Hawaii sovereignty to the US
then it embarked on a campaign to squash
native culture what's one word you would
use to describe what happened here in
1893 channel said there was their intent
to make life hard for us in such a way
would cause our own destruction and
that's what happened it's still
happening it's more passive like
genocide in paradise
it's made official at the White House
President Eisenhower congratulate the
new congressional representatives of
Hawaii adding the 50th and southernmost
state Hawaii officially became America's
50th state in 1959 in 1993 the u.s.
formally apologized for its involvement
in the illegal overgrow of the sovereign
Hawaiian Kingdom 100 years after the
fact that's where the story of how bumpy
wrangled these lush foothills begin in
that apology resolution the u.s.
admitted that Native Hawaiian had never
relinquished their sovereignty armed
with that fact bumpy and 300 others
occupied Makoku Beach they set up tents
and block the area for 15 months
Hawaii's governor asked bumpy to end the
occupation in exchange for a 55 year
lease on this land part of the agreement
was that if and when the sovereign
Hawaiian nation is established this land
would become part of it along with the
renewed fight for independence came a
cultural shift throughout Hawaii Native
Hawaiians began reclaiming traditions
that were once actively suppressed that
meant teaching youth language and dance
getting traditional tattoos using
ancient techniques and fostering
traditional farming and food making but
in reality not much has changed everyone
we talked to during our week there
repeatedly stressed that Hawaii
continues to be occupied illegally it's
very complex
gave up our company
yes
that easily consequences on but we have
[Music]
at a gathering of musicians and
activists in Honolulu the inherited pain
with palpable y'all come from very deep
earth the crime has been committed still
being committed that is part of our
struggle to maintain life but more
importantly one of those rights rooted
in and those rights are rooted in a
country that had its AMA teeth and
recognition stolen by the back they
wanted to stop the pain plumpy sees his
village as a model for
self-determination but for now it's
still partially on the grid the village
runs off 200 amp boxes with houses
sharing power nobody can like have a hot
coal going you know like 100 potli yeah
or like a blow dryer you got to watch
all of it because you guys are off the
grid yeah so what does it mean for
running water we're currently working on
getting water from the molecule Brandon
is bumpy's nephew and one of the village
leaders not politicians we're not
lawyers we're not like you know these
highly schooled individuals were just
Hawaiians exercising our right foot
20 year old beautiful was born and
raised here yeah I went to so I have to
leave the classical school had to get an
education because that's the law
required law I could have been home
school but I rather go out make friends
when people ask you where you live what
do you say to blast me where I live I
tell my living on poor new alumni or we
just call it salty
you call this this offices for some
Native Hawaiians on the outside
sovereignty movement like bumpy's are
beyond symbolic they have a real impact
overall you need those type of people if
we don't shake up things Hawaiian
language would have never been approved
to be part of the foreign language we
wouldn't have Native Hawaiian agencies
to provide us with better health and
wellness nutrition education we fought
for a lot to receive a lot but their
message to Americans in the United
States who might not know much about
Hawaii's history or what you're doing
here
I know if I want to talk to the people
of America they like battling with each
other and all right and so all I can say
is we've been there you know keeping the
America and we still have a lot to
settle with the United States it's not
done hey guys it's Tina be sure to check
out the last video in this series where
I take you back to the studio and
reflect on what I've seen and learned in
my weeks here in Hawaii and let us know
what you think